justin bieber says his marriage to wife
hayley bieber
hasn't always been easy he's a good kid
he's a good part and i love him
the 27 year old singer covers the may
issue of
gq and inside the mag he says that his
first year of marriage was quote
really tough justin and haley tied the
knot in a september 2018 courthouse
ceremony
when he was 24 and she was 21
and had a big wedding a year later in
south carolina
and justin he says saying i do was
always a part of his plan
quote i just felt like that was my
calling just to get married and have
babies
and do that whole thing what do you hope
your life looks like in 10 years i hope
my life looks
hopefully i have a family wife some kids
but despite knowing that marriage was
the right decision for him
he says he spent the first year as a
husband on
eggshells while dealing with some of the
past trauma from his highly publicized
troubles as a child star
quote the first year of marriage was
really tough because there was a lot
going back to the trauma stuff there was
just lack of trust
there was all these things that you
don't want to admit to the person that
you're with
because it's scary you don't want to
scare them off by saying
i'm scared now justin says they have
largely overcome that hurdle and are
building a solid home life together
something justin said he lacked in the
past
my home life was unstable like my home
life was not existing
i didn't have a significant other i
didn't have someone to love
i didn't have someone to pour into but
now
i have that he's really funny we have a
good time together
he's just really sweet justin credits
both haley
and his faith for helping him through a
dark time around
2017. i just woke up one day and i'm
just like
who am i i didn't know and that was
scary to me
the singer explains that despite his
success he was still
sad and in pain and started using drugs
as a numbing agent
and on top of his personal struggles
justin says he lost control of his
vision for his career
but now justin says he hopes he can take
the lessons he learned during the hard
times in his life
and help others avoid that pain i don't
want to let my shame of my past
dictate what i'm able to do now for
people it's an amazing feeling
but despite his troubled past today
justin says
he is at peace
[Music]
i have a wife who i adore who i feel
comforted by
i feel safe i feel like my relationship
with god is wonderful
i believe that at this point in my life
i'm right where i'm supposed to be
doing what i believe that god wants me
to do and there's
nothing more fulfilling
you